c'est malheureusement toujours une
réalité en 2021 de très nombreux jeunes
font face à de la discrimination à
l'embauché et 37 % des 18-34 ans
déclarent avoir déjà été discriminés
dans la sphère professionnelle
les femmes ont 22 % de réponses
positives en moins d'après le défenseur
des droits l'âge le sexe le handicap est
l'origine sont les principaux critères
de discrimination ainsi les personnes
avec un nouveau rythme à gré bull ont 31
% moins de chance d'être recontacté par
des recruteurs que des personnes
blanches avec un cv identiques pour
lutter contre ce phénomène des
politiques de quotas sont mises en place
par les entreprises mais également
directement par l'état ainsi la loi copé
zimmermann oblige les conseils
d'administration des grandes entreprises
à être au moins 40 % féminin les
avancées demande également à toutes les
entreprises de plus de 20 salariés
d'employer 6 % de personnes en situation
de handicap dans leur effectif si en
france aucun quota ne concerne l'origine
ethnique et la discrimination positive
va encore plus loin aux états unis pour
voir trop loin l'université d'harvard a
récemment été accusé pour favoriser
l'intégration de personnes noires de
pénaliser les jeunes d'origine asiatique
les asiatiques qui selon l'université
réussissent mieux en maths partent avec
un handicap de moins 140 points alors
pour ou contre les quotas en entreprise
c'est la question que nous vous posons
ce soir et c'est la question que je vous
pose à tous les trois thibault comment
tu te positionnes sur sur ce sujet les
quotas qu'elle horriblement déjà wow et
a parlé de quotas je trouve qu'on
stigmatise vraiment les choses alors on
eu son quota noir en hausse au quota de
blandas au quota de verre de rouge non
franchement non moi vraiment les quotas
c'est très peu pour moi aucun intérêt
moi je prends les gens tels qu'ils sont
et non pas dans des catégories
classifiés quota de ceux-ci côté de cela
vraiment contre la rencontre çà mau moi
aussi je suis pas du tout pour les
quotas c'est très anxiogène je trouve et
ça implique des sujets qui sont
aujourd'hui en france
3 ou 4 ans qui n'ont pas lieu d'être en
fait exactement exactement vraiment un
fait là pour le coup on va pas avoir
beaucoup de discorde là dessus je suis
un peu je suis d'accord avec vous là
dessus c'est vrai que le mot quota me
dérange après c'est vrai qu'elle la
discrimination partout et c'est vrai que
c'est un vrai problème sur beaucoup des
entrepreneurs des entreprises ou quoi
que ce soit ou kiki complètement dérape
et il faudrait quand même pouvoir
regarder et voir les gens qui dérape
essayer un petit peu de de remettre sur
la bonne ligne mais à la fin c'est moi
je suis un vrai partisan de la
méritocratie c'est à dire que si
quelqu'un si quelqu'un fait quelque
chose d'incroyable quelle que soit sa
couleur de peau sa nationalité sa
religion son sexe eh ben les gens vont
vouloir travailler avec lui et parce
qu'il rayonne parce qu'il est pertinent
et c est et je regrette que les médias
constamment met en scène cette histoire
constamment de quotas et met pas le fond
du problème le fond du problème moi je
pense que c'est l'éducation c'est
d'ailleurs qu'on doit améliorer
l'éducation pour que les jeunes filles
et garçons
améliorent leur culture leur à l'heure
de leur business ça va un tout petit peu
plus loin que ça parce que si lisse le
principe et la notion de quotas est
arrivé comme ça pour légiférer la loi du
travail c'est parce qu'il ya certaines
minorités comme les personnes en
situation de handicap et d'autres qui
étaient sous représentés dans le monde
du travail sous l'immense
aubazac te ment on peut dire que c'était
une notion assez louable qui avait
c'était une assez tchané pour vocation -
vertus d'ouvrir le monde du travail les
personnes sous représente absolument
c'est une initiative très louable même
mais là ça dérape schultz et toutes ses
déclinaisons voilà c'est la maison qui
dérape en suis d'accord c'est vraiment
la déclinaison avoir une loi qui permet
justement de de taper sur les
entreprises qui font n'importe quoi et
qui sont discriminants ça c'est
important d'avoir une loi où on ne peut
plus rien faire ou moi j'ai vu des fonds
d'investissement qui me disent ah bah
cette année je suis désolé moi je peux
plus investir dans des fondateurs qui
sont des hommes par exemple mais c'est
donc là là ça va plus
ça m'aidait des barrières et on ne
regarde plus le mérite on regarde
pourtant je suis énormément évidemment
partisans 100% que les les femmes
entreprendre et
c'est tout après le problème est la
dérive de la discrimination positive on
va embaucher ou favoriser quelqu'un en
fonction de son sexe de sa couleur de
peau de son origine ou autre c'est
plutôt que de son talent de sa
compétence etc en plus de fil en
aiguille il faut une réalité on va
arriver dans un monde qui est déjà en
train d'arriver que si on regarde ya 20
ans par rapport à aujourd'hui on ne peut
plus rien dire on ne peut plus rien
faire et donc ça va s'accentuer mais
après c'est vrai qu'il ya des gens qui
sont discriminés et ça je le sais une
petite lutter contre ça mais par
d'autres moyens plus il ya d'autres
moyens beaucoup pour vous raconter une
anecdote une petite blague mais quand
j'ai élevé des fours la première fois vu
que j'arrivais avec la casquette de
sportifs et et rollerman aucun des fonds
voulait me donner le moindre centime
c'est une forme de discrimination marc
est drôle mais si on dit banon lui si
j'avais fait des études de teck et
jamais les petites lunettes il m'aurait
donné de l'argent simplement parce que
pas crédible par etienne battu les
exactes la méritocratie n'est justement
à plus d'un titre mais il faut en tout
cas punir ceux qui dérape exactement
donc contre les quotas mais contre
également les discriminations et trouver
des moyens plus utile de punir les
entreprises qui discrimine plutôt que
d'imposer des quotas à tout le monde sur
la base de remplir des cases pour que
l'entreprise se porte bien et représente
un maximum de personnes possible c'est
peut-être pas la meilleure des solutions